[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité une opposition qui
ne faiblit pas après l'adoption par le
biais du 49.3 de la réforme des
retraites à l'Assemblée nationale avec à
la clé colère et dégradation urbaine
exemple à Rennes avec TVR dans ce
journal où les agents municipaux sont
mobilisés pour nettoyer les stigmates
des manifestations
alerte sur l'eau après un hiver sans
pluie la situation des nappes
phréatiques c'est encore dégradée en
France TV 7 et via Occitanie nous
expliquerons les conséquences de cette
tendance inquiétante à l'approche de
l'été et si les nounours des tout-petits
se rendaient à l'hôpital rien de grave
ne vous inquiétez pas juste un moyen
pédagogique pour parler de maladies avec
les enfants nous dira-t-elle cette
chaîne de la Loire et puis enfin du
journal il sera question du soin apporté
aux animaux grands ou petits domestiques
ou non nous suivrons le quotidien de
Romane dans une championne de natation
reconvertie en ostéopathe animalier un
métier de passion à découvrir avec vos
télévisions
mais on débute donc ce journal avec
l'opposition à la réforme des retraites
entre motion de censure prise de parole
du président de la République et
manifestation un peu partout en France
la semaine fut encore agitée et symbole
de cette montée des tensions les
dégradations
urbaines sont de plus en plus nombreuses
exemple à Rennes ou après chaque
manifestation les équipes de nettoyage
interviennent reportage sur place de
Raphaël Tondreau Gautier pour thé vert
regardez
9 heures de agents de la mairie nettoie
les murs de cet hôtel des tags injurieux
qui doit être nettoyé en priorité pour
se faire les agents utilisent de
l'hydrogommage et des solutions
chimiques
là je peux intervenir avec le chimique
parce que ça a été fait hier c'est pas
encore totalement sec la même chose
demain ou après-demain il faudrait
utiliser des produits qu'il y a
arracherait la peinture du support donc
du coup là on va peindre directement un
travail de longue haleine qui se fait
aujourd'hui quotidiennement Jérôme
legain va intervenir sur une trentaine
de tags parfois au même endroit
et le dans la nuit ils ont retaillé le
d'où ils ont doublé donc on est revenu
le jeudi matin tout ça pour faire ça
depuis le début de l'année les agents
d'entretien de la ville de Rennes sont
sur
tous les fins des manifestations ils
doivent intervenir rapidement pour
dégager la chaussée et ce sur une
dizaine de points dans la ville il y a
des rues au tout débats roulants les
bacs poubelles ont été renversés donc
une première équipe les amis debout déjà
pour éviter que les déchets
s'éparpillent sur la sur la voie et
aussi en termes de sécurité il est
important de de libérer les espaces
roulants quoi sur les quatre dernières
grosses mobilisations de janvier et
février le montant des dégâts sur la
voie publique avoisinée les 23000 euros
en parallèle une quarantaine d'abrébus
et de panneaux d'affichage ont été
dégradés
puis dans ce contexte pour le moins
tendu c'est la notion même du travail
qui est interrogée par la réforme des
retraites parmi les pistes étudiées pour
mieux répondre aux aspirations des
salariés la semaine de quatre jours
semble séduire de plus en plus
d'entreprises à Brest 90% des salariés
d'une PME travail désormais du lundi au
jeudi un nouveau rythme qui permet à
l'entreprise d'être plus productive
Frédéric Lorenzo pour TBO la chaîne du
groupe Le Télégramme
ici on plie des tôles on les soude et on
fait des pièces pour la construction
navale l'agroalimentaire ou l'industrie
automobile les ouvriers et techniciens
qui travaillent dans cette entreprise
termine souvent leur semaine le jeudi
une semaine de quatre jours officialisée
depuis ce mois de janvier salarié poussé
depuis plusieurs mois vers un vers la
semaine à 4 jours
on hésitait on hésitait quand même un
petit peu par rapport à la réactivité
qu'on aurait pu perdre vis-à-vis de nos
clients finalement voilà on a décidé de
via une phase de test de quelques mois
de tester cette semaine à quatre jours
sur la base du volontariat finalement au
bout de quatre mois plus de 90% des
salariés sont été sur la semaine de
quatre jours donc si ce qui nous a fait
généraliser l'ensemble les 58 salariés
travaillent du lundi au jeudi 8h45 par
jour un rythme qui leur convient en fait
on fait des bonnes journées actives de
lundi au jeudi ou jeudi et ça nous
permet soit de faire des heures le
vendredi ou soit de nous des dégager du
temps la semaine de 4 jours nous apporte
déjà des économies pour les moins de
peser sur l'activité de l'entreprise le
nouveau rythme de quatre jours à même
permis un gain de productivité sur la
partie peinture la chaîne de peinture
poudre qui était allumée le vendredi
pendant que
et qui sur laquelle nous avions une
heure de chauffe et de d'échauffe là le
fait d'avoir travaillé sur sur quatre
jours et ben on a augmenté simplement la
plage horaire sur sur la semaine et donc
on a gagné deux heures de productivité
du coup sur l'ensemble de la semaine
avec carnet de commande plein cette
société créée il y a 44 ans peine à
recruter des soudeurs ou des techniciens
qualité dans les trois dernières
embauches la semaine de 4 jours a été un
élément déterminant pour les candidats
voilà et cette semaine d'actualité a été
marquée aussi par la libération du
journalisme Olivier Dubois l'ex otage
est arrivé en France mardi après presque
deux ans de captivité dans la zone du
Sahel une libération particulièrement
saluée et fêtée en Martinique l'île
d'origine du journaliste sur place
proche des membres du comité de soutien
non cessé ne se battre pour réclamer sa
libération reportage de Jean-Marc
d'abreux pour via TV
dans le bourg d'humour rouge ou le
visage d'Olivier Dubois est encore
visible la bonne nouvelle c'est vite
propagée on pourrait tout ce qu'il a pu
avoir lieu là-bas sa famille
la tente d'Olivier Dubois avait encore
du mal à réaliser la libération de son
père qui m'a appelé pour me dire qu'il
avait eu l'information et que Olivier
allait rentrer sur la métropole d'ici la
nuit ou le matin de la joie du bonheur
pour toute la famille du bonheur pour
les enfants pour sa femme du bois et
toute la famille une bonne nouvelle
aussi pour le comité de soutien
d'Olivier du bois des actions étaient
d'ailleurs prévues à l'approche de
l'anniversaire des deux ans de captivité
du journaliste on a tellement attendu
nous a fait en tout cas la famille m'a
sollicité il y a un peu plus d'un an et
demi en fait on a sollicité des artistes
qui eux vont continuer à distiller le
message et la bonne nouvelle la
libération d'Olivier Dubois correspond
pour le journal Libération la situation
d'Olivier Dubois était un mauvais signal
pour la liberté de la presse c'est une
victoire
pour tous les journalistes pour la
liberté de la presse ou François on
espère maintenant retirer la fiche à
l'effigie de l'exotage en sa présence
un soulagement bien sûr et des honneurs
qui nous conduisent en Gironde où vous
le voyez sur ces images un portrait de
Jacques Chaban-Delmas vient d'être
inauguré dans la ville d'Arès sur le
Bassin d'Arcachon un hommage à l'ancien
maire de Bordeaux restait 47 ans à la
mairie ex 1er ministre également exposé
au côté d'autres résistants dans un
square une cérémonie à laquelle assistée
Alain Juppé lui qui fut également maire
de Bordeaux et chef du gouvernement des
figures politiques importantes de la
Cinquième République saluer par le maire
d'Arès Xavier Danet écoutez-le lors de
son discours
le résistant le Premier ministre le
Premier ministre de la nouvelle société
le gaulliste le président de l'Assemblée
nationale le maire de Bordeaux chacun à
son Chavant chacun pour attirer dans
l'enseignement du parcours de la pensée
de l'action de Jacques Chaban-Delmas
la sécheresse est-elle déjà de retour en
France après une saison estivale
particulièrement grave l'an dernier le
pire est à craindre pour cet été sans
plus abondante depuis des semaines les
nappes phréatiques ne parviennent pas à
se reconstituer selon les spécialistes
en nouvelle-aquitaine par exemple il
faut remonter à 1964 pour enregistrer
des précipitations aussi faibles les
explications de Christophe chavanot pour
TV7 la chaîne du groupe sud-ouest
un mélange de fourrage de foin et de
farine végétale ces vaches laitières
sont encore à leur régime alimentaire
hivernal elle devrait pourtant déjà
brouter quotidiennement l'herbe des
prairies et ce depuis au moins une
dizaine de jours ce ne sera pas le cas
avant la mi-avril minimum faute de
précipitation l'herbe ne pousse pas ou
très peu pas suffisamment en tout cas
pour nourrir les bêtes leur éleveur a dû
se résoudre alors acheter du fourrage au
mois de mars une première ça n'était
jamais arrivé sur cette exploitation
agricole auto suffisante entre le 20
janvier et le 20 février la nouvelle
acquitaine inconnue 30 jours consécutifs
sans aucune pluie un record produire du
lait nous a coûté plus cher donc la
conséquence a été une diminution d'une
dizaine d'animaux à la traite et donc
une perte de production d'une façon
générale on le constate dans toute la
France les éleveurs ont été obligés de
décapitaliser c'est-à-dire d'avoir moins
d'animaux la réduction des troupeaux
d'élevage c'est l'une des conséquences
de cette sécheresse hivernale qui
succède à celle de l'été 2023 dans
certaines zones de la nouvelle Aquitaine
le déficit pluviométrique peut atteindre
40%,
une incidence directe sur les cours
d'eau les barrages et les nappes
souterraines leur recharge n'est pas
complète et le faible enneigement cet
hiver des Pyrénées du Massif Central
n'est pas de nature à changer la donne
au moment où il faudra tous ces
indicateurs mi-boutes à bout negurent
pas une une situation très favorable
pour le démarrage de la saison et de du
printemps et derrière de l'été en
Corrèze depuis le 6 mars dernier
certaines retenus do agricoles n'ont
plus le droit d'être rempli les villages
limousins qui avaient connus une rupture
de l'approvisionnement d'eau potable
l'été dernier sont particulièrement
surveillés bref si la situation
pluviométriques ne changent pas
rapidement la nouvelle Aquitaine devra
connaître à nouveau comme l'été
l'automne dernier de nombreuses mesures
de restriction d'usage de l'eau
et puis des restrictions justement
certaines collectivités n'ont pas
attendu pour en prendre dans les
Pyrénées-Orientales le maire d'une
petite commune a décidé d'interdire tout
simplement les constructions de piscine
une mesure nécessaire explique-t-il mais
qui fait polémique reportage sur place
d'Isaac Bari pourvie Occitanie
c'est un arrêté municipal qui fait des
vagues sécheresse oblige à elle il n'est
plus possible de construire de nouvelles
piscines dans la commune cette décision
fait polémique pour moi c'est un bon
arrêté par rapport à la sécheresse que
voilà on peut pas construire d'autres
piscines vaut mieux boire que c'est une
baigner dans une piscine vu comment une
queue d'eau on va toujours dire que ça
peut être
utile mais j'y crois pas trop parce que
c'est pas par là qu'on va perdre le plus
d'eau au total quatre permis sont pour
le moment gelés selon le maire s'est
arrêté et complémentaire de celui du
préfet ces décisions là c'est pour ne
pas avoir à basculer un niveau de crise
dans quelques semaines et donc si on
veut conserver l'eau pour alimenter les
productions agricoles nourricières et
l'eau potable donc il faut aux humains
pour vivre et bien on a une terre à
prendre plein de mesures pour que l'eau
non essentielle soit pas utilisé le
secteur des piscines est et de plein
fouet par cette crise pour certains
vendeurs il faut vite engager un
dialogue j'ai plus envie de d'avoir
quelques d'avoir un débat qui soit
constructif par rapport à tout ça et de
dire que nous on est professionnel et
qu'on est appuyé par la fédé et que on
est là pour déjà faire de la pédagogie
auprès de nos clients et même nous de se
former justement c'est le problème
environnementaux dont on est conscient
l'arrêter s'applique pour les deux
prochains mois seul condition pour lever
l'interdiction l'arrivée de la pluie
voilà non sans lien passons à présent
aux initiatives pour économiser de
l'énergie et après les voitures les
vélos ou encore les bus les dameuses
elles aussi se mettent à l'électrique
dans la station de Val Cenis un nouvel
engin permet à la fois d'améliorer
l'empreinte environnementale du domaine
et les conditions de travail des dameurs
les détails d'Emmanuel JO pour la
rédaction de 8 Mont-Blanc
comme chaque matin depuis plusieurs
semaines déjà le premier geste de
l'équipe de dameur et de débrancher la
prise une habitude nouvelle mais qui
permet de profiter de ce tout nouveau
modèle de dameuse 100% électrique un
outil de choix pour la station de
valcenis et pour ses équipes de damage
pour qui cet outil est un réel avantage
la machine électrique qui va vraiment
changer ça va être un confort de travail
par rapport à ma hauteur thermique qui
est sous nous qui ronronne qui fait du
bruit qui fatigue c'est fatiguant la
langue quelle électrique c'est la
douceur ça a une piste de ski de fond
une piste de luge à comparer d'une
grosse machine qu'on va envoyer dans les
murs pour remonter la neige que les
skieurs descendent un usage différent
mais surtout une stratégie longuement
réfléchie de la part du village station
engagé depuis près de 10 ans déjà dans
la réduction de son empreinte
environnementale une volonté qui fait de
ce territoire jouxtant le Parc National
de la Vanoise un modèle de premier ordre
afin d'atteindre le fameux objectif de
la neutralité carbone à l'horizon 2037
c'était important pour surtout de
vraiment s'inscrire dans cette démarche
et de continuer cette démarche de faire
tout ce qu'il faut pour que pour que
l'activité ski perdure et pour que ça
perdure il faut qu'on prenne des mesures
comme celle-ci l'obtention du label
flocon vert en est en est une preuve
d'ailleurs si ces engins de damage ne
représentent qu'à peine 1% des émissions
générées au sein de l'écosystème des
stations de ski ces machines bénéficient
aujourd'hui de réelles évolutions qui
permettent de mieux gérer leur
utilisation et le rationalisation les
dameuses électriques ont donc
aujourd'hui toute leur place au sein des
domaines skiables même si déjà ce sont
les dameuses à hydrogène qui commence à
intéresser les grandes exploitations
faire son pain manuellement pour réduire
sa consommation énergétique voilà une
autre bonne idée venue cette fois-ci de
Toulouse la ville rose où s'est
installée depuis presque deux ans
Baptiste Chardin un boulanger sans
machine et qui pétrit notamment à la
main sont levain une méthode
inhabituelle mais largement adaptée à la
crise énergétique précision et image au
micro de Manon von Overbeke journaliste
à La Dépêche du Midi
ce que j'ai voulu faire dans ce modèle
là c'est créer le pain le plus simple
possible à savoir vraiment choisir des
blés anciens de l'eau filtré mettre deux
fois moins de sel c'est un pain qui va
éviter beaucoup de problèmes et
problèmes d'hypertension les problèmes
intolérance au gluten si je devais cuire
des baguettes sur un étage de mon four
je curé trois kilos pour un étage à peu
près
alors que là je rentre à une douzaine de
kilos donc on est sur quatre fois moins
d'électricité consommée
de la boulangerie à la cantine
penchons-nous à présent sur la santé des
tout-petits à Limoges où l'on sait plus
qu'ailleurs l'importance d'une assiette
en porcelaine les enfants des crèches
ont aussi le droit vous allez le voir à
de la belle vaisselle pour leur repas
fini donc les plateaux plastiques un
changement pour lutter contre les
perturbateurs endocriniens un exemple
suivi par des établissements de
plusieurs grandes villes de France
d'ailleurs Alain Druot passa table pour
cet aliment je regardais
simple comme bonjour et pourtant il aura
fallu attendre un plan de lutte contre
les perturbateurs endocriniens pour que
les enfants des crèches de Limoges
mangent dans de la porcelaine de Limoges
ont été déployés à l'ensemble des
structures de la ville d'abord chez les
chez les enfants les plus grands donc
les enfants âgés de plus de 2 ans et
fait secondaire bénéfique la forme de
l'assiette supprime les allées et venus
le repas complet de l'entrée au dessert
et servi en une seule fois tout tout de
suite donc il y a moins de personnes qui
circulent autour des tables donc ils
peuvent manger des tranquillement ils
ont de l'entrée jusqu'au dessert cette
réussite limousade séduit d'autres
municipalités plus de 7000 assiettes ont
été vendues jusqu'à présent on a du
travail à la main fait par nos artisans
et chaque produit reste unique on est
arrivé au niveau national les grandes
villes Strasbourg la région parisienne
dernièrement on a fait Marseille c'est
bien des crèches publiques que privées
fabriquées avec le même soin qu'une
assiette de service de table la
Geneviève c'est son nom et même devenu
un cadeau de naissance rechercher
et si le doudou de votre enfant allait
se faire soigner à l'hôpital une idée
qui peut paraître surprenante mais qui a
son intérêt permettre aux enfants de
mieux appréhender le monde hospitalier
un sujet d'Anthony verpillon pour TL7
dans la Loire
pour certains c'est une grande
découverte et dans ce cas il est
préférable de venir à l'hôpital avec son
doudou et rien de mieux que de prodiguer
soi-même les soins pour s'immerger
complètement dans les lieux on va voir
si tout va bien au niveau des pattes je
te laisse le marteau on va taper les
petits réflexes je laisse taper là
pido sur cet exercice d'une bonne
demi-heure où elle a suivi le parcours
de soins complet de la radiologie aux
séances de kiné en passant par le bloc
opératoire
on est d'accord donc on va devoir
l'opérer mais pour ça pour pas qu'il ait
mal on va l'endormir alors on va prendre
ça c'est toi qui va le faire et on va
lui mettre sur la tête et même une
séance chez le psycho nounours
et pourquoi il a peur des mots
avec moi j'ai la peur parce qu'il avait
un loup une initiative bienvenue pour
l'enseignante qu'il avait déjà
expérimenté l'an dernier en classe et
non pas à l'hôpital directement ça
permet de démystifier pour les enfants
donc la douleur le contact avec les
soignants le matériel voilà un rappel
sur l'hygiène des dents était aussi
apporté car le but est de parler de
pathologie que les enfants sont
susceptibles de développer on va avoir
au titre angine on peut avoir la
varicelle notamment on peut avoir les
gastro tout ce qui est grippe aussi ce
qui est cancer tout ça maladies qui sont
trop graves on évite d'en parler on
touche vraiment que les maladies qui les
concernent dernier moment fort la visite
du camion de pompier une petite dizaine
de classes stéphanoises seront invités à
suivre cet exercice jusqu'à vendredi
voilà et si eux non plus de Doudou
depuis longtemps il n'en reste pas moins
concerné par la santé dans l'Oise 500
lycéens viennent de participer à une
semaine de formation au gestes de
premiers secours objectif leur apprendre
à réagir face à des situations d'urgence
alors que seul 20% de la population
connaît les gestes qui sauvent un sujet
de Jérémie ou Bron pour rué au TV la
chaîne de la Voix du Nord et du Courrier
Picard
on met l'autre main sur le front on
ouvre la bouche et avec le travail on
écoute et en même temps on regarde son
abdomen cela peut paraître simple mais
suffit parfois à sauver des vies ils
sont élèves en première et se forment au
gestes de premier secours après la
théorie place à la pratique sur des
mannequins de plastique c'est un peu
physique pour faire le massage mais
après c'est facile à utiliser avec le
défibrillateur ça fait peur parce qu'on
se dit que ça nous arrivera jamais de
par exemple de sauver quelqu'un mais ça
peut arriver n'importe quand massage
cardiaque position latérale de sécurité
garrot les lycéens vont ainsi apprendre
à réagir vite et bien face à des
situations d'urgence vitale des
connaissances indispensables selon les
bénévoles de la Croix Rouge formateur du
jour pour moi personnellement oui je
trouve qu'il y a besoin d'apprendre
c'est juste là si on les sait pas voilà
on pourra pas sauver des vies on va y
avoir une appréhension on va l'avoir
plein de choses quoi bon déjà on est te
rassuré de connaître les gestes bah on
va aller plus facilement vers la victime
une petite piqûre de rappel pour ceux
qui ont pu appréhender ces gestes
notamment au collège une véritable
découverte pour d'autres je pense à un
truc que vraiment important à savoir
faire parce que si j'avais été vraiment
rêvé j'aurais été incapable de faire
quoi que ce soit porté par le Rotary
noyonné l'initiative permet un pas moins
de 500 lycéens de se former pour sauver
de quoi combler quelques lacunes en la
matière en France il y a 50 000 morts
par an et on n'est pas assez formés ça
doit être une cause nationale dans les
autres pays en Belgique en Hollande les
gens savent les gestes qui seront en
France pas assez en France seul 20% de
la population est formé au gestes de
premiers secours ces lycéens sont
peut-être ceux qui transmettront à leur
tour c'est savoir pour préserver encore
plus de vie
prendre soin des hommes mais aussi des
animaux partons à la découverte d'une
profession méconnue dans ce journal
l'ostéopathie animalière une activité
que pratique notamment romane dans les
Vosges cette ancienne championne de
natation manipule aussi bien les corps
des animaux de compagnie que ceux de la
ferme Thierry Lasson et Hélène leplabre
ont suivi dans son quotidien un sujet de
vos télévisions
vous allez pousser un petit peu à l'aise
quelques exercices de rééducation pour
des patients un peu particulier romane
est ostéopathe animalière la spinalienne
intervient à domicile pour soigner chien
chat chevaux et vaches avec un protocole
précises avec le propriétaire où on va
lui poser tout un tas de questions sur
la vie de l'animal après on va avoir la
partie palpation on va vraiment recruter
toutes les tous les phénomènes en fait
de résistance à la pression et après on
va faire ce qui s'appelle les tests
articulaires on va vraiment tester tout
l'animal et en fonction de ça on va
prendre en charge ou non les clients
font appel à romane pour des problèmes
musculaires et articulaires mais aussi
pour les troubles digestifs de leurs
animaux récemment elle avait rendez-vous
à raonchant pour un félin bien mal en
point
j'ai ma petite Olga qui marche plus
depuis trois ans donc je voulais
vraiment lui donner une chance quoi
d'essayer de remarcher jours même si ça
me paraît un peu compliqué mais bon
c'est pour la soulager surtout en une
heure et après quelques exercices
bénéfiques pour ce chat il faut déjà
repartir pour soulager un poulain de
deux ans pas vraiment le même gabarit
Lotfi c'est le nom de ce poulain qui ne
sait toujours pas remis d'une mauvaise
chute le vétérinaire a déjà vu l'autre
fille à plusieurs reprises sans rien de
concluant et on remarque à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui que il est toujours dans
le même état donc je voulais vraiment
qu'il soit y manipulé et vu par une
ostéopathe pour le soulager en tout cas
de ces douleurs l'aspinalienne
ex-enageuse de haut niveau voulait
devenir vétérinaire mais une rencontre a
tout changé je suis parti à Toulouse moi
après le bac pendant deux années pour
pouvoir continuer à nager et continuer
mes études donc je suis en train en fait
de bio de base pour faire des études de
vétérinaire et j'ai rencontré un
comportementaliste canin qui m'a dirigé
vers ce métier d'ostéopathie pour les
animaux la jeune femme ne vit pas encore
de son activité et travail à mi-temps
dans un supermarché mais elle espère à
terme pouvoir se consacrer pleinement à
l'ostéopathie animalière
citoyen au service du patrimoine local
dans l'Aube des bénévoles n'ont pas
hésité à retrousser leurs manches pour
écouter bien nettoyer le clocher de leur
église celui-ci était recouvert de
fientes de pigeons grattoir pelles et
sauts ont donc été nécessaires pour
cette entretien particulier filmé par la
rédaction de Canal 32 regardez
un accident au clocher les membres de
Giraudeau patrimoine découvre une
structure recouverte d'une épaisse
couche d'excrément de pigeon c'était
pour mettre en les cloches à sonner
enfin système automatique et je me suis
dit bah tiens on va aller voir comment
ça vieillit et là j'ai été effaré de
voir l'entretien qui avait à faire
vous voyez tout ce qui est par terre là
c'était dessus dans cet état là tout ce
qu'on voyait plus rien on se renseigne
sur les produits qu'on peut mettre en
oeuvre pour préserver également le
bronze c'est de bénévoles prévoient
l'équivalent d'une semaine
d'intervention pour retirer les fientes
et poser les grillages à bientôt 80 ans
le président de Giraudeau patrimoine
découvre pour la première fois
l'intérieur la vue et ses merveilles
devant les cloches et alors là vous
pouvez remarquer
un simple frottement ça conduit à une
résonance qui est très longue là on a
une Paulette on a quelqu'un en 39 on a
une autre personne en 18 ça fait plaisir
de voir que on participe
à cette histoire Giraudeau patrimoine
organise 5 à 6 animations annuelles pour
reverser des fonds à la Fondation du
Patrimoine et entretenir l'église malgré
des travaux de restauration des
contreforts achevés en 2021 aujourd'hui
le maire a l'impression que l'Église est
à l'abandon en janvier dernier elle
apprend que la réalisation des deux
nouvelles tranches des travaux et
reportés après selon elle 10 ans
d'attente c'est un édifice qui est
remarquable qui est déjà identifié dans
la route du vitrail portée par le
Conseil départemental donc c'est à dire
qu'on met en valeur le patrimoine des
vitraux principalement de l'édifice et
là on peut pas le montrer il y a une
déception du fait que j'ai rhodo n'était
plus une priorité pour les services de
l'État je sais pas en fait quel est
l'avenir pour pour tout le projet sans
attendre l'association garde le cap de
nettoyer bénévolement le clocher
gérodopatrimoine prévoit de refaire le
plancher d'installer un éclairage afin
de faciliter l'entretien de l'édifice
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci d'avoir suivi ce grand JT des
territoires on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle édition au revoir à
tous
[Musique]